[Music]
thank you
and finally when Britain opened its
doors to the Hong Kong Chinese following
beijing's Camptown in 2020 they came
here in their hundreds of thousands but
why do we know so little about what is
one of the biggest migrant groups to
arrive in modern British history for the
magazine this week I write that they
will make as much of a mark on Britain
as a Windrush generation did joining me
now is Reverend Dave ho young whose
church is helping new arrivals in Leeds
to settle in and Simon Chang who was an
activist in Hong Kong and granted asylum
in the UK in 2020. he now runs the
organization Hong kongers in Britain
Simon Chen and Reverend Dave ho young
welcome to spectator TV Now Dave I want
to start with you because it's really
through talking to you that I first got
to cover this incredible story of Hong
Kong migration to the UK can you tell us
about the welcome sessions that your
church has been putting on
yeah so um our church up in Leeds um has
been doing these these welcome sessions
for new arrivals from Hong Kong for uh
probably probably around about 18 months
now and we have been working with a UK
charity called Faith action who've put
together some informal English classes
and we were asked to be one of the uh
the kind of um uh churches in in the in
the Yorkshire region who would kind of
roll out this course so we've been doing
that for since probably since April 2022
and I think we've probably had around
about 200 or so uh people from Hong Kong
coming through the course over those uh
over those uh uh year and a half and for
you this is quite a personal calling too
isn't it because you're off mix British
and Chinese Heritage yourself but that
it has been a complicated Heritage in
the past
yeah so uh so my dad came over from Hong
Kong to the UK to study back in the back
in the 70s he met my mum uh they got
married had a family and he lived here
for a little while until I was about 10
and then my parents separated and he
went back to to Hong Kong and uh so so I
kind of was brought up without really
that that kind of Chinese or Hong Kong
Heritage uh I came coming from a very
kind of uh White area of the of the UK
conference Shropshire so not known for
its diversity in that in that part of
the world
um so so being Chinese and wasn't kind
of a massive part of my uh my story
growing up but in the last couple of
years it's something that I have been
discovering more about and something
that I've been exploring uh kind of
personally in terms of meeting family in
Hong Kong and then that has kind of
dovetailed with with the arrival of so
many people from Hong Kong to the UK and
particularly to to the parish that I I
work in which has kind of been a kind of
a a major area that people from Hong
Kong are wanting to to move to if they
come to Leeds what I've found I'm so
lovely when I talked to you earlier in
the year was how you were telling me
about practicing English with the people
who go to these welcome sessions but
they were teaching you Cantonese in
return as well which you know it really
bringing that Heritage back um now Simon
the reason we're talking about this is
because in the last two years uh through
the British Nationals overseas passport
route the British government has allowed
uh over a hundred thousand and the
precise number is 125 000 Hong kongers
to move to the UK now you yourself are
one of those new arrivals and you had to
leave Hong Kong because of your
political activism now I know you've got
an organization here in the UK now where
you're helping the new arrival so what
can you tell us about the new Hong
kongers who are coming over you know
where do they go what sort of
backgrounds do they have what kind of uh
what kind of work do they do what kind
of people are they
yes uh thank you Cindy for having me and
we understand that you know this Visa is
quite comprehensive that's it opens for
almost all bno Visa holders that's the
coming to the UK so it would be a bit
different from the past that's when
people hurt they immigrate into UK
either they could be more uh
well-educated then they could be more
well-off density could come to the UK
owning uh like the job Visa or in Faster
Visa but this time that is really open
to the maths public so it really
comprehensive but generally speaking uh
this bunch of people coming to the UK
they are more living in the environment
of international City more well educated
and of course that stay would be
familiar with the UK culture so I think
there's batch of the immigration will be
quite specific that they share some
historical linkage with the UK
and your organization has done a study
with the University of Liverpool I saw
which where you found that 79 of the new
arrivals are University educated many
come many come with cash from selling
their Hong Kong Flats because the
average Hong Kong flat is 1.5 million
pounds
um so they're not your usual political
refugees but Simon do you think is
politics that's mainly driving them here
I think so because that's the people
come in here for obvious reason at least
that is also the background of the Visa
policy so I guess the people that come
in here they have more concerned about
their own children's future they want to
live in a country with the academic
freedoms I think that is the most
important thing and there's a bunch of
people they also believe in that online
could be flourished because they could
also seek for freedom and moxies and
here perhaps a few years we develop such
a excise Community or new communities in
here and we think we're moving to a new
phase that you know prefix that we think
the migrants as a label we need to be
supportive but this time we think we
could take leaks for change we could be
engaging more uh within UK Society so
recently I've been fun to uh by many
governments then also to launching
different types of programs to train
some we call it Community leaders or
Community organizers from Hong Kongs to
be in the UK to learn more about what's
the UK culture would be mmm that's
pretty I mean Dave you've also had a
similar experience to that where one of
the people who was attending your
welcome session as a new arrival is now
helping you run those welcome sessions
yeah absolutely absolutely I think um so
we we cut we've kind of run two
different uh uh sessions uh two
different programs sorry and we're kind
of just on to the third program now and
uh so so actually two of the people who
who did the first session are are
helping us to to run uh the sessions now
and pretty much taking a lead in in sort
of Hosting uh and planning uh each of
our sessions uh and in general
um what what are the challenges do you
see for the people that you come in
contact with Dave
um the people that are coming to your
church
um you know they they we've outlined the
ways in which they are and much more you
know in many ways privileged and your
unusual new arrivals but they still have
challenges tell us about that
I think the main I mean I guess one of
the main challenges is is language we're
finding that most people from Hong Kong
have a good level of English but they
they just don't feel as confident as
they as they would like to in terms of
English so that's that's one barrier
um another one is is uh employment so
lots of people particularly people who
came uh in the first ways uh were very
successful in Hong Kong they had very
good jobs whether in whether in finance
or in other areas and what pretty much
everybody has found coming to the UK is
that they they can't work at the same
level that they they did in Hong Kong so
they uh so they're having to take jobs
perhaps in the same sector
um but jobs that are uh a couple of
grades down and certainly don't pay as
much as they as they as they did in Hong
Kong um and some people can't get into
that into the sector that they worked in
at all so doing something completely
different but yeah that step down I
think is quite hard for a lot of people
to to kind of adjust to yeah I spoke to
a couple of people at some Barnabas
Church where you know they might have
done Property Management in Hong Kong
now they're working in a restaurant or
they might have done otherwise a white
collar job and now they're having to
think about retraining in beauty or
going to a warehouse something like that
I mean Simon presumably that's also
quite representative of the Hong Kong
when you come across it what do you
think the government can do to make
things easier
well I think recently that's the
government launched a different programs
of funding for VCS organization to
provide support and also the government
prioritize employment support would be
the top parity because this bunch of the
community usually had been banned from
accessing public funds except they have
been in destitution
so that is also really important and for
giving them some confidence usually we
are experiencing some culture shocks our
academic and employment qualification
experience need to reflect into the UK
market and that is also important that
how can we start uh easier because we
have been lit off the credit history to
start even the bank account I think it'd
be quite useful to many ethnic minority
groups or migrant groups uh just like
what we are now experiencing but also
something that might a bit a bit unique
for us that how the eager government
could give us the Assurance of our
freedoms and safety even in the UK we
know that you know the UK China
relations sometimes change from time to
time and how to make sure that the
security of the and the guarantee of the
security of our people living in here
will be intact uh we will not be
harassed by any suspected informants or
agents of the CCP regime and that is
also really important topic for the UK
government
yeah absolutely Simon I mean as as we
know there is huge tension between the
Hong Kong Chinese Community here in the
UK and Mainland Chinese Community as
well do you think that the authorities
understand the nuances there you know
where a lot of Hong kongers who have
just come here often associate the
mainlanders with the CCP title beijing's
control and then vice versa there's also
a bit of resentment from the other
direction so do you think the British
authorities understand that kind of
complication I think there is still a
learning curve for the UK government's
the super servants to uh to to to know
the situations of the Hong Kong
Community I think the uh also major part
for us to address is about the mental
trauma we have a collective memory uh
what happens back in Hong Kong that has
like really common to see the separation
of the family disagreements among
different family members they will feel
lonely in here they will feel upset that
they are now living in freedom but men
any of their filaments and their people
may be staying in the prison they have a
sense of guilty how can we address this
and also how can we restore trust
amounts our community members especially
as you mentioned with the British
Chinese Community will be really
important I don't think that it's only
about your own political opinion but
also under this situation especially
after the imposition of the National
Security Law in Hong Kong the threat is
also really obvious and black and white
on paper on the legal document so I
think the people they have a genuine
concern for this and that is also the
people have a concerned of they'll be
left behind when the UK government now
try to engage back with China and will
that the promise to the freedom of Hong
Kong and the human rights issues about
Hong Kong and other you know as a
minority in China will be brought back
to on the table and that will be also
important to see the attitude of the
yukagne
and finally Dave wearing a moment in
public discussions in this country where
migration is a very sensitive topic you
know we've had I would say success
stories like the Ukrainian refugees and
the Hong Kong refugees coming over but
there is also a really live question at
the moment over things like the Rwanda
scheme over things like migrants from
other places the small boats crisis
how do you see the fact that you know
there has been so little backlash or
even discussion of you know the
population of Eastbourne in terms of
Hong Kong is coming over to the UK in
the last two years is it because
um they're very good at integrating and
before your experience working on the
ground what do you put that down to
um
personally I think it seems a bit of a
hidden migration I think uh people are
kind of aware of of what's been
happening in Hong Kong over the last
couple of years and and lots of people
know that Hong Kong is uh are coming to
the UK
um but I think it is very much hidden
it's kind of spread all across the
country I think other other groups of of
migrants
well there's obviously the the people
crossing in boats guess all the
headlines uh people coming from
Afghanistan uh from the evacuation a
couple of years ago it gets all the
headlines Ukraine gets a lot of the
headlines but I think Hong Kong hasn't
had the same exposure in the media that
perhaps some of the other migrations
have so I think it is in a sense quite
invisible uh you know particularly to
people who don't pay that much attention
to to maybe what's going on in Hong Kong
Simon does that wider rhetoric against
uh new migrants in general does that
worry you and the Hong kongers that you
come across yes I don't think we should
fall into the narrative that what is
good migrant or migrants because always
that you know like Hong Kong has come in
here uh we're always being framed as
pretty much more educated well-off Etc
but actually as associations we receive
quite many cases that's actually they
need to be supported they might not be
always being living in The Stereotype or
some kind of people and that has much
more uh like more vulnerable groups that
state their voices need to be Amplified
and I think this rhetoric you know the
migrants group sometime I think uh we
need to empower uh you know that is the
same that you know the migrant set we
always see some carved people they need
some support and help and you know it is
it's really normal and usual we try to
bring it to the media into other people
to know like you know migraines also
just the same as the local residents and
so they want to be and they actually
they are local wrestling now in the UK
Simon Chen and Reverend Dave ho young
thank you so much for joining us by HTV
[Music]